so in this time whether we look at the
time of fascism or we look at the
fictional Animal Farm what's the heroic
action then so uh kamu joined the
Communist Party
there's a bunch of different heroic
actions somewhat heroic than others
not just for the you know Heroes the
wrong word in terms of like
Effectiveness what's the effective
action I guess is what I want to ask as
a writer as a thinker as somebody with a
mind was the heroic action that's a
tricky question because a lot of times
in the west heroism is regardless
intertwined with martyrdom right so it's
kind of this idea of like you have to
speak to you know can we always talked
about just let Justice be done though
the heavens fall this is a common
um kind of motto among people with
conscience and that you have to do the
right thing even the consequences might
not be what you like and I think that is
a good loose definition of heroism so if
you me I'll give you one example of
heroism this was on Twitter and I really
feel bad that I don't remember the guy's
name uh this was the line to Auschwitz I
believe it was and you know there's the
Nazi guards keeping everyone along and
uh if you were a certain I think if you
were under 12 they killed you or
something there was some age limit where
some kids were killed or some were not
there were some circumstances and he
asked the mom how old this kid was and
she's like he's 14 and she's like no
he's 12 and she's like no he's nice 14
she goes he's 12. and she realized what
this Nazi was telling her even in that
circumstance and it ended up saving the
kid's life so I think heroism in this
context is Defiance and standing true to
values of liberalism humanism and uh
venerating the sanctity of human life I
think that uh and I think it's also
important to pick your battles uh I
don't think if you know he got that Nazi
over there gotten a bullhorn and said
hey this is the rules blah blah blah
blah that's not going to help anyone do
anything so I do think you know people a
lot of times attack me from my Anarchist
views it's like oh you know would you
call the police would you use the roads
would you pay your income taxes uh you
know I I got an argument with Tim Poole
because there was that couple I think in
was that Missouri or Illinois when they
were had their guns and they were being
arrested and they basically took a plea
deal and he said you should have thought
I go it's a lot easier to say you should
fight but we don't know what
circumstance someone is under and what
these totalitarian regimes did very very
well as as you know is if you were a
Target and they can't get through to you
that's fine you have a family so you can
sit there Lex and gird your jaw and you
can stand up till the torture cool what
are we gonna do about your wife what
about your mom one thing Stalin did he
made it a law
that kids up to uh 14 and up could get
the death penalty for certain crimes so
after that the rule was from the nkvd if
you were interrogating someone they
would have death warrants for the kid's
child on the desk visible so I'm
interrogating you asking you to uh
commit to I'm sorry to admit to some
crime that you're not committed and
those piece of paper it's it's you know
Svetlana she's got a death warrant
you're gonna admit to any crime you want
so this is something Americans this is
even the case right now in North Korea
um which I know you had janmi Park on is
something I talk about a lot let's talk
about instead of the hypothetical but
this is happening right now on Earth you
can look at the map on Google uh the
great leader Kimmel sung the founder of
North Korea said class enemies must be
exterminated to three generations so
North when people talk about
individualism versus collectivism uh
Rick Centaur for Miss Sanders says the
family is the basic unit of society unit
North Korea takes that seriously the
family is punished as a unit so someone
does something wrong three generations
have to pay the price and you often
don't know who it is that got you all in
trouble there's not a trial this to
Western Minds is something almost
incomprehensible it's a lot easier to be
brave
one is just your skin there's something
when it's when it's yeah when it's your
child your your loved ones your every
man becomes a coward but also what
bravery is there for me to write an
essay for the guardian to say I don't
vote there's no consequences to me
there's no possibility of consequences
to me this is the wonderful thing about
living excuse me in a free country uh it
would take a lot of courage to be in the
Soviet Union and say I'm not going to
vote and what would that courage
accomplish uh very little so I think
hair wisdom in the sense of kind of the
suicidal stuff and taking a stance with
no consequence it is a bit overrated
there is some aspect like the way I
think about heroism is something like
you said about the Nazi Soldier which is
quietly privately in your own life lived
the virtues that you want the rest of
the world to live by yes so like without
like writing about it is um is not as
heroic as living it quietly I'll give
you a great example of this I sometimes
give talks on networking and I tell the
kids
if you know someone's in town and it's
their birthday with nothing to do take
them out and I say I do this for selfish
reasons and everyone laughs and I go
think about it this way the guy who
takes people out for their birthday is
awesome that could be you like you have
that capacity to be that person and
you're making that day feel special
they're going to remember for a long
time what's the cost dinner 30 bucks 25
bucks so they're it's it's very
disturbing to me how often people have
opportunities to slightly move the
needle and make things a bit better at
almost no cost and they just literally
don't think in those terms and one of
the things kamu talked about you know
he's often described as a existentialist
which he did not like that term he
required himself as an absurdist is the
idea that we're basically blank canvases
and this isn't something that is
dangerous this is enormous opportunity
and you have the ability to become the
kind of man or woman that you admire and
want to be you don't have to be you know
I don't know George Washington or one of
these great Heroes of all time but
everyone out there has the capacity
capacity excuse me to be a hero to their
kids or to be a hero to maybe some
there's there's nursing homes and
there's old people who are lonely I
think that you take in a dog that's on
its last legs uh uh these are little
things Terry Shepherd does that a lot of
regard him as a hero
um these are not Terry Shepherd I'm
black man's name these are things that
people do
um that aren't heroic in the sense of
Superman but that I find admirable
extremely and I think are very
underrated because these people aren't
championed is this some kind of weird
passive aggressive and direct way for
you to tell me that I should take you
off for your birthday on Monday
is that why you gave that whole speech
that's that wasn't it at all that was a
joke Michael no it was a failed joke
nevertheless there was no punch line
without failure we would not have
Triumph